[Music]
how's it going everybody Wonder Woman -
is well underway with its filming we've
seen photos that the actors and director
have leaked themselves and we've seen
photos and even videos of the filming by
fans and we're probably going to
continue to receive these leaks because
they're filming in pretty public places
especially when you film outside it's
really hard to keep people from the
borders of the set and it's even harder
to keep people from recording but it is
thanks to those people and those leaked
photos and recordings that we get a
little bit of an insight of what's gonna
happen in Wonder Woman - and just
yesterday we received a video that
appears to be Wonder Woman in her
invisible jet so today we're going to
talk about Wonder Woman's invisible jet
and what it could possibly mean for
Wonder Woman - but first take a look at
the bottom right of the screen you see
that little red subscribe button press
it we'll be doing a giveaway soon that
involves given a few copies of Avengers
infinity war out some cool speakers and
other things and all you have to do is
subscribe there are a few different ways
that Diana Prince gets her invisible
plane in the comics but the original way
that she gets it is from her home the
mascara and the Amazons so I can see a
few things lining up from the comics to
the movie here for starters Wonder
Woman's invisible plane is introduced in
sensation comics number one in 1942 and
Wonder Woman uses it to carry Steve
Trevor back to his home in Washington DC
and as we've seen Steve Trevor is back
from the dead or he never died we don't
really know and they're filming around
Washington DC but one interesting thing
is that in the comics that Amazon's give
this plane to Wonder Woman so she can
make flights from the mascara to places
all across the world but in the MCU it
is said that Diana cannot return to the
mascara so maybe we'll actually see her
go back to the mascara and Wonder Woman
to another connection to the comics is
that it was decided that one woman would
venture forth into the mana world of
mankind that is when they decided to
give her the invisible stealth plane
it's been said that Wonder Woman to
Diana is gonna have to deal with a lot
of things relating to the time that
she's in so dealing with modern times
it's a subject in the comics and it
seems to be a subject in Wonder Woman
too and maybe that's how they're going
to link the plane to her
Wonder Woman could interact with this
specific plane via telepathy and her
tiara which had electronic devices in it
and she would use these to command the
planes course and flight patterns but
there are also other invisible planes
and other ways that she gets these
invisible planes the second invisible
plane that Wonder Woman received was
actually from an alien race called the
Lanson Ariens the Lanson Aryans
originally have the invisible plane but
they crash land on earth and Wonder
Woman ends up saving them in return for
her saving their lives they grant her
the plane and this plane is more
sophisticated it actually has artificial
intelligence the plane is so
sophisticated that it actually responds
and is commanded by Diana's thoughts it
can actually shape-shift as well it can
turn into anything that Diana desires
that could be a motorcycle a submarine a
plane anything she wants which actually
seems like we are seeing here in this
video that the fan took it just seems
like there are way too many cars around
for her to be in a giant plane but she's
clearly riding something and it clearly
is going to be invisible judging by this
video so maybe it's a motorcycle maybe
it's a chariot cuz she's done that in
the comics or maybe it's just a really
small like hovercraft
and I think of anything this is the
plane that we'll see because she can't
go back to the mascara supposedly right
so this would make the most sense that
an alien race would crash land and she
would be gifted at somehow and then
another version is that Bruce Wayne
actually builds her an invisible plane
because this past version of the plane
ends up being destroyed I definitely do
not think this will happen because Bruce
Wayne probably isn't even born in the
time that this film takes place in 1984
I mean even if he's 40 years old in
Batman vs Superman when him and Diana
first meet that would put him around
eight years old
in 1984 and Bruce Wayne's a genius but I
don't think he was at age
or at least he wasn't a genius enough to
be able to build her an invisible jet so
I don't think that's gonna happen
but I am really excited to see it on
screen because it's such an iconic piece
to the comics the first Wonder Woman
movie and what we've seen so far of the
filming of the second one it seems like
they've actually done pretty good at
doing justice to the comics so I really
am very excited to see what Wonder Woman
1984 has in store for us
especially because the first Wonder
Woman movie was so good so there is the
leaked footage of what appears to be
Diana in the invisible jet and there is
a little backstory on it as well
let me know what you all think about
potentially the invisible jet beam and
Wonder Woman too before you leave don't
forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on Wonder Woman to DC Marvel
and all things super thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]